How do you stop a lightsaber
mid-swing? Why, you use the Force,
of course. But who are the Star Wars characters
who have pulled off this incredible ability?
After returning to the Star Wars spotlight in
the last episode of Ahsoka, Ezra Bridger is back
in action for the show's latest installment. In
"Dreams and Madness," Ezra teams up with Sabine
Wren to take on the marauders of Peridea,
Grand Admiral Thrawn's night troopers,
and Shin Hati. Naturally, between her knowledge
of the Force and lightsaber abilities, Shin poses
by far the biggest threat — but both Ezra
and Sabine are prepared for her attack.
"She's like you, but lacks your sense of humor."
"Lightsaber?"
"Oh, yeah."
"Great."
Boldly, Ezra wields nothing but the Force
in his fight with Shin, even using it to
hold back one of her lightsaber swings. It's an
awesome moment in the midst of a frantic fight,
and it proves just how strong Ezra has
become as a Force user. For reference,
in the Disney+ series Obi-Wan Kenobi, the fearsome
and immensely powerful Darth Vader uses a similar
technique during his brief clash with Reva. Vader
uses the Force to prevent several of her strikes
from landing and even prevents her specialized
double-bladed lightsaber from spinning.
These aren't the only Force-users to have
nailed this impressive ability, however.
Ezra and Vader's move has also been depicted on
the big screen via the Star Wars sequel trilogy.
Though the return of fan favorites
such as Luke Skywalker, Han Solo,
and Princess Leia were a big selling point of the
sequel trilogy, these movies also boast a number
of franchise newcomers. Among these heroes
and villains are Rey Skywalker and Kylo Ren,
who clash throughout The Force Awakens,
The Last Jedi, and The Rise of Skywalker.
And it's their duel in the third film that
is particularly relevant here. In The Rise
of Skywalker, Rey and Kylo cross sabers in
the wreckage of the second Death Star. As
gigantic waves crash around them and their
situation becomes increasingly perilous,
they both manage to employ the same
technique as Ezra Bridger and Darth
Vader. Early on in the fight, Rey briefly stops
Kylo Wren's red lightsaber by using the Force,
prompting him to do the same when
she attacks moments later. Seeing
as Kylo is the grandson of Vader and Rey
is the granddaughter of Emperor Palpatine,
it's perhaps no surprise that they've both
mastered this immensely useful Force ability.
And here's a little known fact, for you — at
one point, another famous Jedi was supposed to
use this power. Long before fans saw
Ezra Bridger, Darth Vader, Kylo Ren,
or Rey Skywalker stop lightsaber swings with the
Force, Lucasfilm was hard at work wrapping up the
Skywalker saga. The Rise of Skywalker was the
film that ended it all, though the version of
Episode IX fans saw in theaters in 2019 was
vastly different from the one envisioned by
the film's original director, Colin Trevorrow.
The script for Trevorrow's take on the story,
known as Duel of the Fates, has been online for
some time. Some interesting features include Finn
leading a full-blown stormtrooper uprising,
Kylo pursuing even more dark side power,
and a now-infamous stage direction that
claims Hux "lost the Star Wars." At one point,
this script also includes a pretty wild move
pulled off by the Force ghost of Luke Skywalker.
As The Last Jedi ends with Luke passing into
the Force, it's no surprise that he's present
in the script for Duel of the Fates. Luke
pops up here and there throughout the story,
taunting Kylo from beyond the grave, and it
all culminates in him making his presence
truly felt during Kylo's final duel with Rey.
During this fight, Luke grabs hold of his
nephew's lightsaber by the flaming, crackling
blade — look deep enough on the internet and
you'll even find the concept art drawn up for
this moment. It's an undeniably cool visual,
even if it is a move that living Star Wars
characters would be wise not to replicate.
Clearly, this Force block ability is becoming more
and more commonplace in the franchise. We'll just
have to wait and see if any more characters use
it as the Star Wars universe continues to expand.